let's go to your voicemails two one nine
two david p we have a box about what is
the voicemail a butterfly ovo defraud
yeah here okay let me set this up i feel
like i I speak clearly on the program
like I make my positions clearly known
and every once in a while I will get an
email from someone who has so
misunderstood my position on an issue
that I start to question my ability to
communicate effectively I really do and
this one is about voter fraud take a
listen to this one David it's very
disappointing that you have bought in to
the voter fraud lie it's been proven for
every years for at least a decade the
voter fraud does not it is not a problem
in this list 2016 the few people that
voted twice voted for Trump I know so of
course that won't be mentioned of course
it's mentioned yeah I've been talking
for years about the fact that in-person
voter fraud is not a problem I I'm
trying to think back I can't I don't
know how someone could come away with
this impression that my view is that
in-person voter fraud is an issue voter
suppression is the issue voter fraud is
not an issue but it's used to suppress
the vote yeah we did a story about this
last week and I literally made the point
yes from 2016 the few instances of voter
fraud were from Trump supporters and
then we talked about yes its Republicans
trying to prove how easy it is to get
away with this and it's never easy to
get away with it that's exactly what
we've been talking about I apologize to
the entire audience if I am ever less
than clear on issues that I'm passionate
about if it is confusing but I hope most
of the audience knows my position on
this we've got a great bonus show for
you today I'm out of time but trust me
folks this is a good bonus show get
access at david pakman.com slash
membership